[Musica]
[Applauso]
chissà quanti di voi parlano
l'inglese immagino
molti parlato un'altra lingua vi siete
mai chiesti Quante lingue esistono al
mondo
di cui 2300 soltanto in
Asia certo difficile districarsi tra
tutte queste lingue Ma secondo voi
esiste qualcuno che le possa parlare
tutte Mi sono posto questa domanda e ho
fatto una ricerca scoprendo che il
signor zalf libanese detiene il record
per il maggior numero di lingue parlate
sostiene di essere in grado di parlarne
58 Adesso vi rendete conto della Fortuna
che ha questo
signore poter parlare con tantissime
persone lavorare viaggiare in tutto il
mondo costantemente supportato da un
senso di sicurezza e affiancato da una
delle dalla conoscenza di una delle 58
lingue che parla per capire e farsi
capire dagli
altri credo che questo sia un elemento
fondamentale perché immagino che sia
capitato a tutti almeno una volta nella
vita di parlare con qualcuno che non ci
capisce
se siamo in viaggio Oltre a perderci una
moltitudine di informazioni legata a
quell'esperienza perché ignoriamo la
lingua del luogo è facile cacciar nei
guai non parlare altre lingue al di
fuori della propria ci crea una grossa
barriera di sicuro il signor fazan non
proverà questa sorta di
ansia ma ne siamo
sicuri siamo sicuri che anche anche lui
seppure in maniera ridotta non provi la
stessa limitazione nei confronti delle
7000 Men 58 lingue che non
parla ognuno di noi può provare una
sorta di frustrazione nel tentare di
comunicare con qualcuno che non parla
come noi ma se ci fosse la possibilità
di abbattere l'effetto Torre di Babele
ed essere compresi da tutti o meglio da
un gruppo di esseri viventi che potremmo
inserire nella parola tutti senza alcuna
differenza sarebbe una cosa
stupenda il mio primo vero cane è stata
doxi una femmina di labrador che
purtroppo oggi non c'è più Immagino che
molti di voi abbiano un cane o lo
abbiano
avuto parlate il
canese sì laa dei cani non saprei
proprio come definirla
altrimenti considerassimo questa lingua
al pari delle 7000 riconosciute forse
avremmo meno problemi di interazione con
i
cani qualcuno mi potrebbe dire scusa che
mi frega me di parlare con un cane se
non è uno certo Anche questo è
vero però provate a pensare a tutti
quegli incidenti di cui sentiamo parlare
e in cui i cani sono
protagonisti cane che ha sbranato la
signora Mentre gli dava da
mangiare cane che ha morso il bambino
che lo
accarezzava cane che ha aggredito il suo
proprietario mentre giocavano o
semplicemente cane ha battuto perché ha
aggredito
qualcuno sono tutte condizioni queste di
Forte disagio per il cane in cui le vere
vittime solo apparentemente sono coloro
che ricevono
l'attacco inserirei piuttosto in questa
categoria anche i cani che portati al
limite per
qualcosa reagiscono in maniera
spropositata Sono sempre convinto che
gli animali i cani non abbiano alcuna
colpa e che sia l'uomo non sapendo
comportarsi in determinate
circostanze porti ad un livello di
stress talmente alto da portare i cani a
reagire senza saperlo li portiamo
all'eccesso eppure i cani per un istinto
di
sopravvivenza Prima di arrivare al
limite applicano una serie di protocolli
e inviano una serie di segnali di
avvertimento per evitare il
conflitto perché questo in natura non
conviene Ma noi siamo in grado di
leggere e interpretare bene questi
segnali Allora forse comprendere il
linguaggio dei cani potrebbe riguardare
chiunque non solo chi ne possiede uno ma
anche chi ci si potrebbe trovare davanti
per
caso bene oggi parleremo di questa
lingua che possiamo chiamare banalmente
canese è una lingua che si esprime
prevalentemente per segni fatta di
regole segnali emessi e segnali
percepiti e che i cani applicano di
continuo con ogni loro interlocutore che
sia un simile o
no Certo poi la questione se davanti
hanno qualcuno che sia in grado di
comprendere questa lingua ma loro
intanto la
parlano questo tema Mi ha sempre
affascinato devo dire anche un po'
stressato perché l'idea di non essere
compreso da qualcun uno è veramente
angosciante e occupandomi di cani per
mestiere ho sempre sognato di potermi di
poter essere compreso da uno dei miei
cani talmente bene tanto da parlare una
lingua come oggi sto facendo con
voi Io me lo volevo portare
però eppure in
passato mi è capitato di provare un po'
questa
sensazione e mi stavo preparando per il
brevetto di unità cinofil da salvataggio
in acqua difficoltà erano notevoli Vai a
metterti d'accordo con un maschio di
labrador che deve fare tutto ciò che gli
chiedi mentre nuotate fianco a fianco in
direzione di una persona che rischia di
annegare Eppure una notte ho sognato che
mentre mi allenavo con Codi lui a un
certo punto si gira e mi dice
Oh finalmente ci capiamo e lo ha detto
nella mia stessa
lingua Io ho capito la sua come fosse
stata la
mia il senso di liberazione È stato
incredibile È stato come se mi si fosse
aperto un nuovo mondo improvvisamente
Tutto
chiaro Peccato che era solo un sogno
infatti vi dico la delusione la
mattina mi sono detto Ma è mai possibile
che non ci sia un modo per provare
quella sensazione realmente E ho anche
subito pensato al signor faz che per
quanto parli molte più lingue di me
Magari prova la stessa difficoltà nel
tentare di comunicare con un
cane a distanza di anni da quel sogno mi
è capitato qualcosa che mi ha portato a
vivere realmente quella
sensazione mi trovavo per una strada di
Palermo quando un branco di cani mi ha
attaccato ho invaso il loro territorio
di pertinenza con il mio monopattino
Eh c'è da capirli questo affarino
rumoroso che schizza via per il loro
territorio a un certo punto mi si sono
presentati davanti tre grossi Cagnoni a
protezione delle Femmine che stavano
dietro tivamente mi sono
fermato sono sceso giù dal monopattino
voltato a sinistra per una strada
laterale allontanandomi lentamente di
spalle pensando che questo potesse
bastare per arrestare il loro attacco ma
non fu così Anzi lo ha aumentato Ecco
che d'istinto il canese mi è venuto in
aiuto senza saperlo mi sono comportato
come loro senza accorgermene
Mi sono voltato ho mostrato il mio
fronte al branco di cani ricordandomi
che se mi fossi allontanato di spalle
avrei ricordato loro dato loro la
sensazione di una preda che scappa
stimolando ancora di più l'istinto
predatorio e quindi aumentando l'attacco
Inoltre ho voltato lo sguardo
lateralmente per evitare un contatto
visivo con il leader del branco che
subito Ha capito il mio
segnale si è bloccato e han usato per
terra aveva capito il mio segnale e mi
ha mi ha risposto con un altro segnale
la sensazione di essere stato compreso
da quei cani è stata liberatoria non
solo perché mi ha permesso di dire che
non volevo essere un pericolo per loro
ma anche
perché mi ha consentito di mettermi in
salvo Qualcuno potrebbe dire che si è
trattato di un
caso però io ho vissuto Questa stessa
esperienza ben altre volte nella mia
vita sempre con cani di Strada ottimi
comunicatori e all'emissione di ogni
segnale di quel tipo ho ricevuto sempre
la stessa risposta da parte
loro a questo punto non ho più creduto
al caso ho cominciato a prendere questi
segnali che mi sono scambiato con il
branco e a trattarli come una vera e
propria lingua appunto Il
canese il mio primo cane è stato Erasmus
un grande
Terranova il classico primo cane di
famiglia che ci ha permesso di
commettere tutti gli errori che un
neofita possessore di cane alle primarmi
possa
commettere quando sono andato a vivere
da solo doxy è venuta con me era una
femmina nera intelligentissima con cui
ho fatto ogni tipo di percorso di
addestramento non solo perché mi dava
molto filo da torcere Data la mia
inesperienza di allora ma anche perché
mi piaceva fare delle cose con
lei però c'era sempre qualcosa che non
andava rimanevo sempre con un senso di
insoddisfazione interiore è un dubbio
incredibile ma Comè possib
dell'ennesimo percorso in
campo sembrava di non aver concluso
nulla
e continuava ad avere gli stessi
problemi nella sua
gestione questo tarlo che si presentava
di continuo nella testa mi ha spinto ad
indagare a cercare risposte ovunque a
studiare e ho cominciato ad osservare
doxi gli altri miei cani i cani in
generale E i lupi e mi sono reso conto
che l'unico beneficio che provavo da
questa da Ogni esperienza in campo era
il consolidamento della nostra relazione
per il solo fatto che facevamo delle
cose divertenti
insieme era solo lei che mi dava le
risposte
migliori e a questo punto ho avuto la
consapevolezza che trascorrere del tempo
di qualità insieme al proprio cane con
la consapevolezza di sapere come
funziona E come comunica un cane era ciò
che
contava
ho riconsiderato questi segnali che mi
sono scambiato con il branco che mi ha
attaccato ricordandomi sempre di una
vera lingua e li ho applicati con doxi
con gli altri me cani con tutti i cani
che incontro ho iniziato a parlare il
canese sapere che il cane ha un suo modo
di esprimersi fatto di regole di segnali
anche se non usa la parola come noi mi
ha radicalmente
cambiato studiavo il comportamento di
dei cani già da tempo ma sapere di
potermi rivolgere a loro con un
linguaggio ben preciso mi ha permesso di
creare una relazione
migliore tra gli elementi più studiati
di questa lingua ce ne sono
alcuni sono alcuni segnali che il cane
mette sono quelli che mi sono scambiato
alcuni con il branco che mi ha attaccato
e che ci dicono Molto su cosa ci sta
dicendo il cane in un determinato
momento il suo stato d'animo
si chiamano segnali calmanti li ha
studiati li studia tutt'ora la dog
trainer no verges e tour drugas e ce ne
sono talmente tanti da costituire una
vera e propria lingua ed è divertente
metterli Provate anche
voi stasera quando tornate a casa
osservate Il vostro cane vedrete che ne
emetterà alcuni in determinate
circostanze ad esempio quando
interagisce con un altro cane o un altro
animale Se ne avete uno oppure quando
interagisce con voi stessi osservatelo
bene registrate quelli che emette più
frequentemente e ettet lii anche voi
Vedete cosa
succede avete mai tentato di fare una
foto al vostro
cane e lui invece di mettersi in posa si
volta dall'altro
lato oppure una volta che date uno
occhiata alla foto appena scattata vi
accorgete che è venuto con la lingua sul
naso non vi sta prendendo in giro vi sta
parlando aver puntato qualcosa dritto
negli occhi dà fastidio a
chiunque no che sia un dito uno sguardo
insistente un po' di fari che richiamano
molto una condizione dell'obiettivo
della macchina fotografica una
condizione di contatto visivo diretto
occhi su su occhi che in natura richiama
una condizione
conflittuale siete mai stati ad una
festa Dove c'è qualcuno che vi fissa
insistentemente e che però voi non
volete incontrare cosa fate voltate lo
sguardo addirittura vi girate Beh state
emettendo lo stesso segnale che emette
il vostro cane nel momento in cui gli
puntate L'obiettivo della macchina
fotografica
contro stessa cosa
Ecco perché dopo anni e anni di studio
di questa
lingua venuto naturale spontaneo volgere
lo sguardo altrove davanti il leader del
branco per evitare un contatto visivo
diretto e per inviargli il messaggio non
ho intenzioni
conflittuali
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
[Applauso]
no